michael says from 13 on he was raised by
a single mother is that a fact
i know he had a father he had an issue
with his old man
um
indoctrinated with dysfunctional woman
jada has indoctrinated him with her
bs
yeah he's
yeah he's right he's right jada has
indoctrinated him with
all that nonsense all that spicy wussa
equal equilibrium stuff
will needs to find his
will needs to lift up his skirt and grab
his balls look
well if you're watching this now this
isn't to disparage you or discredit you
you're clearly a successful guy it's
just
when it comes to
what you've done in your personal life
and there's a lot of stuff that covered
that you said there's only two women in
your life that you felt like you could
satisfy or that you felt comfortable
with one was your daughter and the other
one was your grandmother if i'm not
mistaken i don't think you mentioned
your mom
but those are so
you know your wife or other women that
you've dated it's because you you've
gone head over heels backwards plugged
into lies doing everything that you can
put them up on a pedestal and i present
to you
over and over again
you treat her like a celebrity
she's gonna treat you like a fan
you're the a-list celebrity
right what you need to do in a scenario
like that is
i'm gonna go out and bring the bacon
home babe
take care of the house raise the kids
you know make sure everything's sorted
you know when i get back when i'm doing
my shoot my scene my training whatever
it is that you you know you've got to do
during that case and she's a compliment
to your life none of this well if i
can't make her happy then we have to go
out on our own and make each other happy
independently and we're going to pork a
few people on the side and come back and
try to make each other happy like this
complicate life justify why
complicate life justify this is what
guys do they constantly are complicating
their life and justifiable well
she wasn't happy so i told her to go off
and make herself happy and then come
back and present each other to each
other happy and then that'll be fine
like does that does that not sound like
complicating life and justifying why
you've been doing it
it's one thing after the other with guys
like this
it's so bizarre to me that you know we
have all these
super super successful men out there
millionaires even even billionaires like
the whole bezos saying
you know again i'm going to cover that
clip separately but
a lot of these wickedly successful
people
a-list people
great influence huge followings right
massive audiences like
i'm sure that book's gonna
like
it's gonna make
it's gonna make the best seller list
undoubtedly it's going to make him a
fortune
you know like he's he's he's done
everything he's done music he's done
movies he's done great movies in fact
you know he's got a a book that's come
out i'm sure it's going to be a great
book he's obviously going to have an
interesting life you know to talk about
his biography
world-class people that that are like
dealing with tupac scraps you know
tupac's leftovers
dealing with entanglements you know
dudes 53 years old and his
47 year old something wife at the time
is out hanging out with some
20-something-year-old dude that's
friends with his son
because he needed my attention and help
he was going through a difficult time
and we became friends and then it turned
into an entanglement
duh
that's what happens when you send your
woman off and apparently
apparently let's see if we can find it
here i'm going to take this
earpiece out it keeps falling
apparently august
let me see if i can find that clip
blessing i think it was blessing
will smith's blessing
august claimed here it is
august claimed that will smith gave him
his blessing to embark on a romance with
jada
he said i actually sat down with will
and had a conversation due to the
transformation of the marriage and
partnership he gave me his blessing
you're married
oh yeah just go
have fun
and then you see him sitting at that
table for four minutes with his with his
heart getting shattered into a zillion
pieces
look up chris pratt's wife looking at
him oh yeah there was um that's a good
point this is what genuine desire looks
like
there's a
social post a couple of um
a couple of uh like hardcore uh
libby's got very upset about this
chris pat faces uh criticism over post
about his wife looking at him
can you believe that
catherine schwarzenegger oh catherine
schwarzenegger what is he married to
arnold's daughter
hang on
why why is this playing music
what's the problem with all these
celebrity gossip sites
catherine schwartzen yeah i guess he's
married to uh arnie's daughter here it
is right here let's share it on the
screen
attaboy chris
that's what genuine desire looks like
this is this is what you want
you know when you invite a woman into
your life
you don't want to complicate it and take
tupac scraps take tupac's leftovers you
want a woman that's going to look at you
like this and take care of your house
raise your kids so you can go out and do
your movies right this guy
i don't know what this relationship is
like
could potentially fall apart like i said
nothing's forever sometimes it's just
your turn in fact most of the time it's
just your turn for being honest
but this is a good example of what
genuine desire looks like
thanks for pointing that out
uh where is it sam whiskey will smith is
liked by a lot of people but he's not
respected
well he's definitely not respected by
jada because
when a woman respects you
she doesn't do or say the things that
jada pinkett has said about will smith
in that marriage and he certainly sure
as hell shouldn't be talking the way
that he does about her
he just overdoes it it's like the whole
shower here with all that stuff right
like again you know it's amazing to me
you have all the money in the world you
have access to all these different
resources out there
like there's any number of guys that
somebody like will smith could be like
okay
who can who can help me unplug from this
right like something's not working here
i mean the first step is coming to the
realization that
it's not jada's fault it's not
hollywood's fault it's not the kid's
fault it's not his ex-wife's fault it's
not tupac's fault it's not whoever wrote
men in black or i am legend or whatever
it's none of their fault it's his fault
he needs to take a look at the world and
say why am i not getting the results
that i should be getting in my
relationships in my life
you need to unplug you're plugged into
lies bro
she obviously didn't love him if she did
none of this nonsense would have
happened
yeah see
when a woman go gets with another guy
it's because she's basically done okay
women can't go and sleep with like six
different guys simultaneously some can
some are a little you know what i'm
saying but generally speaking women
don't want that they just want because
they're hypergamous they want the best
guy that they can get
that's what
hypergamy is the best guy
i can get
it's not the best guides i can get
sometimes when it comes to the alpha
seed and the beta knee part of the
equation there might be more than one
guy in the equation where
you know
some guy who's the alpha chad provides
the seed and some pleb
raises
that man's seed
but there's
no environment in which you know women
have run harem you know where they've
run dozens of you know men in their
lives i mean if you look at even even
muslim culture right
they can have four wives
what in what culture do are women
you know with
four different dudes five eight you know
16 24
where show me
it's not rocket science but guys like to
complicate their lives right
appreciate the content listening at work
thanks man guys hit the like button it
just it just helps me out with the
algorithm thank you appreciate it and
again if you have a question
q a is open
there's a
pinned comment at the top of the youtube
so just click that and join in
he needs a mail therapist or something
yeah
send him send him your book rich i know
it helped me a lot um
i'll i'll i'll fly down and talk to him
you know face to face and sort them out
it wouldn't take me longer than a day
damn
honestly i mean
it's crazy
honestly it just it just drives me
bonkers like you know you're like you're
a weapon in every area of your life and
you're all over the news the media you
know your wife's on the view saying that
talking about your sex life talking
about entanglements you're sitting at a
red table
talking about some guy that's like
25 years younger than you that your wife
became friends with
he became friends and he was having a
lot of pain and we had to deal with that
and then we got into an
entanglement uh we're going into an
entanglement
it just happened
you know he just i just tripped and fell
and he tripped and fell inside of me and
then we just got entangled
complicate life justify why right this
is what happens
it's nuts
goes to show you no matter all you know
doesn't change a woman's nature
will needs to wake up but either way
her needs to walk
sorry either way needs to walk away from
jaina
yeah this like you know they're gonna
keep
from what i've seen they're they're
basically saying
we have the most imperfect marriage and
and you know we're gonna do this for
life and it's like a fist bump like you
know high five like a fist pump like
this is what i saw in some of the
interviews i think this is the one from
the red table
your kids are grown up
she's making a mockery of you
he talks about in his book trailer by
the way i didn't i didn't play the whole
trailer i mean you go see it on his
youtube channel but he talks about in
the book trailer
how he had contemplated taking
a very permanent step to whatever
temporary problems going on in his life
at that time
okay
that's not good
listen i've been there i've been in that
situation where you where you
contemplate taking a very permanent step
to temporary problems going on in your
life that is that is bottom of the
barrel type of
that is that is not a good place to be
for any dude
you do not want to ever get there
if you ever get there ask for help like
do not don't don't go and do something
stupid just talk to somebody
call into my show i don't like i'm i'm
on every monday night lines are always
open
you